Welcome back everyone this will be my joker 2
video todd phillips just dropped a teaser for
the movie with a couple really big easter eggs
revealing something about the plot so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos and i will
explain where this fits in the continuity because
they just announced dc's black label and they also
said that todd phillips would be advising them
on doing other types of movies like the joker
franchise movies which will be separate from what
matt reeves is doing with the batman movies and
all of those spin-offs like a slightly different
continuity but it'll all make sense don't worry
but recently you probably saw on your feeds todd
phillips dropped a teaser for joker 2 with joaquin
phoenix like the movie is real it actually exists
now and they'll get ready to shoot it really soon
there was a title reveal and the full script
like it's basically good to go because we're
getting ready to film it the title is pronounced
joker folie a deux in its french for joker shared
madness as in joker's shared psychotic episode
it's a term in psychology used to describe when
multiple people share the same delusion the
same psychotic episode in the context of the
movie it has multiple meanings it's about how
the joaquin phoenix arthur joker character has
this sort of madness delusion about the world
living in gotham city this delusion about being
thomas wayne's illegitimate son it also means
that through his actions the crimes he pulls
off during the sequel on the scale that he does
that he's going to cause the rest of the city
that we saw towards the end of the first movie to
share in his madness metaphorically and literally
because we are talking about the joker here like
in some batman stories the comics the animated
series the tv shows the movies all the different
versions you see joker try to dose the city with
his joker serum the laughing serum in the context
of arthur's joker character in the first movie it
was more of a metaphorical thing because the crowd
was already in the middle of rioting because of
the current state of gotham city in this big class
divide in what was going on with the mayoral race
and thomas wayne's run for mayor the way they
play things during the joaquin phoenix joker
movies is more real world instead of going full
comic book like the justice league snyder cut
and all the movies related to that line like the
black adam movie that i just did a trailer for
the fun fact about the joker serum too is that
it's actually derived from the scarecrow fear
toxin but we haven't had the scarecrow inside the
joaquin phoenix joker universe yet and even though
it is possible that he could use some version of
the joker serum during this joker sequel i don't
think they're going to play it that way i think
they'll keep it in the realm of metaphor when he
talks about sharing his madness with everyone like
through his actions through the media people will
watch it like the people who are riding it'll
just get crazier and crazier and crazier and
he'll start to win them over through his actions
and they will then begin to share in his madness
it's not like he's gonna go around dumping a bunch
of fear toxin or joker toxin into the water supply
that's the really cool the really insidious
thing about the first joker movie is that he
doesn't need any kind of joker talks and like
that it's all about the role of the media and
all this like in the case of the first movie it
was his broadcast at the end that helped push
his exploits to legendary status but at the
time he was already building on an existing
system of riots that all the people in gotham
had been upset about the current administration
the growing problems in the city the whole
inequality between the common people who were
rioting in the ultra-rich people represented by
thomas wayne bruce wayne's family he was in the
middle of running for mayor and there were
these escalating series of riots throughout
the movie as things got crazier and crazy and
crazier public outcries during his appearances
eventually before he went full joker at the end
of the movie he called the crowd a bunch of clowns
so already things were going really crazy in the
city and what was happening with the joker just
kind of tipped that over the edge the whole thing
with him secretly being thomas wayne's son i think
was actually a bit of a misdirect but the way the
movie plays it they want to be kind of ambiguous
about it because you're meant to be viewing
everything in the film from arthur's perspective
so as he descends into madness you're meant to
see things get crazier and weirder and weirder
like they wanted you to feel as if there might
have been a possibility that he was thomas wayne's
son and they never confirmed that it wasn't true
even though they implied that it was all just this
big delusion in reality i think that his mother
had suffered from mental delusions like he does
in the movie like she had had mental episodes
when she was younger and she just fell in love
with thomas wayne when her family was working at
his mansion and started to get creepy at his house
and then they just imply that his family kind of
pushed her family out the door like okay you go
off on your own no more working for us and she
just descended into a form of madness and just
came up with this delusion that she had been in
a relationship with thomas wayne when that really
wasn't the case so he's not really thomas
wayne's son but during the movie you notice
even after thomas wayne yells at him and they have
that episode together that big encounter he calls
him a crazy person arthur does not stop believing
that it's true he's still obsessed with the waynes
so the idea is that he had played a party clown
and thomas wayne had called the people like him
like the lower class people a bunch of clowns
acting crazy he started to feel like his life was
a joke eventually he just kind of owns all that by
wearing the name as his own mantle calling himself
the joker matt reeves actually had his version of
the barry kyokin joker in the batman movie kind of
say something similar like it's not so bad being a
clown let me tell you there are worse things to be
hey hey don't be sad the big difference during
the batman movie though is the ages of the batman
and the joker and the joker is in prison in
arkham asylum because batman put him there
they released a deleted scene that was meant to
be on the one year anniversary of him putting
him in prison so the barry kyogen joker was joking
about that with him like isn't it our anniversary
so if it wasn't clear now obviously matt reeves
has confirmed that the joker in his universe is
not going to be the joaquin phoenix versus the
joker and even though they are doing all this
crazy multiverse stuff with the flash movie the
joaquin phoenix joker movie will still be set in
an alternate universe in joaquin phoenix said he
would totally come back as long as the story was
right the team was right and it sounds like they
worked all those things out i can't stop thinking
about it i talked to tom a lot about what else
we might be able to do um in general just working
together but also specifically is there something
else with joker that that might be interesting
you know i think me and todd would still be
shooting now if we could right because it seemed
endless um the the possibilities of where we
could go with the character and if they didn't
start filming till 2023 that means a 2024 release
date which would be a good long while between
movies it's still going to be rated r it's still
going to be part of dc's black label which is
what they're using for their darker more hardcore
films especially ones that are set in alternate
universes that aren't necessarily connected to all
the big dceu stuff most of the plot details are
being kept in an underground bunker as you would
expect but based on what both phillips and phoenix
had said previously the movie isn't going to have
like a massive time jump the original movie took
place during 1981 joaquin phoenix is in his 50s in
present day in real world but he was playing a 30
40 something joker and i do think that he actually
did kill this woman the psychiatrist but when
you see him walking down the hallway leaving the
trail of bloody footprints and the music swells up
that part is all happening in his head like he's
in the process of escaping from arkham asylum
but the way the prison break plays out in this
scene it's meant to be his fantasy version of
things if we were to see what's actually happening
here in reality you'd see him running down the
hallway covered in blood crashing through random
people orderlies looking for the exit stabbing
people left and right it would be way more quick
and dirty like some of the other killings that he
did during the film so any references to batman or
any of the other pre-existing dc characters in the
joker sequel is just meant to be a coincidence
or in the case of this version of batman just a
totally new different version of batman the joker
sequel is mostly just meant to move forward a
little in the timeline to the next logical event
in gotham so bruce wayne would still be a child
living with alfred he'd be a little bit older but
still be a child and there wouldn't be a bunch of
batman stuff happening yet the other really big
change that you probably just heard about that i
mentioned earlier was todd phillips separately
being asked by the new powers that be at dc at
warner brothers to come in and advise on doing
more films kind of like the joker in the same
vein like talking about more dc black label types
of movies that means more mid-budget movies like
movies that are closer to like 90 100 million
dollars about villain characters different from
what you would think of your traditional big
superhero type of dc film like a batman movie
matt reeves has talked about doing lots of
spin-offs for his characters like there's
the arkham asylum tv show there's the other batman
based tv shows on the robert pattinson version of
batman that's not meant to be dc black label stuff
all the stuff that todd phillips would be doing
or helping advisor producing at warner brothers
if other directors come on to do them is meant
to be a different line of continuity one of the
exceptions now would be like doing a riddler film
like they just did the batman movie with robert
pattinson the riddler was the main villain even
though it sounds like he's only inspired to take
the name the riddler by the end of the film like
he hasn't fully become comic book riddler yet but
he's thinking about it in the cell there with the
joker so todd phillips would probably swerve
on doing a black label riddler film but there's
many many other villains in the dc toy box that
they could do personally i actually think that's
been one of dc's strengths they just announced
that marvel is finally doing a thunderbolts
movie and they said that they pitched it kind of
like the marvel version of a suicide squad film
one of dc's big advantages over marvel the past
couple years has been their willingness to do
r-rated villain-based films don't be surprised
that they also take the same approach with the tv
stuff on hbo remember though dc black label stuff
intended to be different continuity but i think
we'll just take that on a one-at-a-time basis
like when a new show or new movie comes along
i'll talk about where it fits in the continuity
but everyone click here for my brand new black
adam trailer video and easter eggs and click here
for my brand new marvel thunderbolts announcement
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!